Hey what's up guys it's good to be here
my name is Hans Kim and I'm not a very
intimidating fella. I can tell by the way
you guys are still on board with this
premise. Everyone feels really safe right now and it kind of makes me insecure.
Something about my presence inspires confidence in others.
I think that's what makes me a good leader of men
When I walk into a room people are like I suddenly feel like testing the limits of my physical
abilities right now.
I'm  glad I could inspire that kind of confidence
I'm not a big fan of
crowds. Crowds are my least favorite
thing next to individuals.
It's the individuals in them that make the crowd so unbearable.
I don't understand people who brag about having
been spanked apparently you weren't
spanked hard enough because you're still
an arrogant person. It's not even effective.
I saw a Netflix special recently that had canned
laughter on it
and that kind of annoyed me as a
comedian you know what if instead of
canning the laughter why don't you just dub in better jokes
you have the technology. Either we can
fake 500 genuine human emotions or we
can get one guy to work harder. Do better at the thing
you're famous for. I live in my car so I
can pursue somebody full-time so if you
don't think I'm very funny
I'm sorry I'm trying my hardest I literally
don't know what more I could be doing
puts a lot of pressure on me now now
people are like yeah that was funny but
not live in your car funny
You could have written that joke in an apartment buddy.
I woke up today and I was like I wonder what
the temperature outside is like and I
was like probably exactly the same as
the temperature inside this car.
It's weird how science works
it's tough to date as a van dweller. Turns out dates like shelter.
So what usually ends up happening if a person wants to go home
with me is we go for a drive until
I can work up the courage to tell her we
arrived 45 minutes ago